I heard great story about you that Lorne
Michaels when I first got hired at
Saturday Night Live he heard you love
Jack Nicholson as we all do yeah we all
think he's great
yeah anymore Michael said to you you
know kid I'm gonna invite you over my
home because jack is gonna be over and I
know how much you love Jack and wisely
and I commend you for this he said I'm
not going to your house to meet Jack
Nicholson yeah explain why because I I'm
in full agreement with so it's British
that's pretty accurate the we were in a
LA and he was having dinner with Jack
Nicholson and Jon Hamm right and he was
like would you like to come I was like
no I was like no there's nothing I could
what am I gonna just do like you guys
are gonna have conversations about stuff
you could relate with and I'm gonna be
like hey I can't live with Jack
Nicholson hating me
yes and you're uncomfortable with being
at that dinner because you're afraid not
he's gonna meet me and he's gonna
[ __ ] hate me or he's gonna think why
is this [ __ ] case why is this dump
ahead at our billion dollar table